The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome once again to our
Calculus Revisited lecture,
where today we shall discuss the
concept of infinitesimals,
a rather elusive but very
important concept.
And because most textbooks
illustrate this topic in terms
of approximations, our topic
today will be called
approximations and
infinitesimals.
Now, how shall we introduce our
subject in terms of topics
that you may be more
familiar with?
Perhaps the easiest way is to
go back to an elementary
algebra course, to distance,
rate and time problems, when
one talked about distance
equaling rate times time.
The question, of course, is what
rate do you use if the
rate is not constant?
You see, the question of
distance equals rate times
time presupposes that you are
dealing with a constant rate.
Now what does this mean, and how
is it directly connected
with the development of
our calculus course?
This shall be the subject of
our investigation today.
See, the idea is this.
Let's consider the curve 'y'
equals 'f of x', and let's
suppose that the curve
is smooth.
That is, that it possesses a
derivative, say, at the point
'x' equals 'x1'.
Let's draw the tangent line to
the curve at 'x' equals 'x1'.
Now the idea is this.
In general what we investigate
in a calculus course is the
concept known as 'delta y'.
'Delta y' geometrically
is what?
It's how much 'y' has changed
along the curve
with respect to 'x'.
It turns out that there is a
simpler thing that we could
have computed.
Notice, if we look at this
particular diagram, that since
the tangent line never changes
its slope-- and by the way,
when I say tangent line I
mean at the point 'x1'--
that once we leave the point
'x1' the tangent line, in a
way, no longer resembles
the curve.
But the point that is important
is that I can
compute the change in
'y' to the tangent
line here very easily.
And the reason for this, you
see, is rather apparent.
Namely, the slope of the tangent
line is, on the one
hand, 'delta y-tan' divided
by 'delta x'.
'Delta y-tan' divided
On the other hand, by definition
of slope, the slope
of the line 'L' is also
equal to what?
It's 'dy dx'.
It's 'dy dx' evaluated at the
point, or the value, 'x'
equals 'x1'.
You see, in general the slope of
the curve varies from point
to point, so when we talk about
the tangent line we must
emphasize at what point
on the curve we've
drawn the tangent line.
At any rate, from this
particular diagram it is not
difficult to see that to compute
the change in 'y' to
the tangent line, that this
is nothing more than what?
'dy dx' evaluated at 'x' equals
'x1' times 'delta x'.
And you see this is not
an approximation.
This is precisely the value
of 'delta y-tan'.
The approximation seems to be
when we say let 'delta y-tan'
represent 'delta y'.
In other words, we get the
intuitive feeling that as
'delta x' gets small, the
difference between the true
'delta y' and 'delta y-tan'
also gets small.
Another way of saying
this is what?
Our intuitive feeling is that,
in a neighborhood of the point
of tangency, the tangent line
serves as a good approximation
to the curve itself.
Now let's see what this
means in terms
of a specific example.
I've taken the liberty
of computing the
cube of 4.01 in advance.
It turns out to be 64.481201.
And it's sort of arbitrary,
like cubing this.
If this if this doesn't look
messy enough for you we could
have taken this to the sixth
power and then we could have
squared this.
But that part is irrelevant.
A simple check shows that, more
or less, this will be a
correct statement.
And what I would like to do, you
see, is simply illustrate
what our earlier comments
mean in terms of
this specific example.
Let's suppose I want to find
an approximation for 4.01
fairly rapidly.
The idea is this.
What I do know is one number
that's very easy to cube,
which is near 4.01,
is 4 itself.
In other words, I know
that 4 cubed is 64.
And by the way, I've
deliberately drawn this
slightly distorted according
to scale so that we can see
what's happening over here.
What 64.481201 represents is
the actual change in height
from here to here
along the curve.
In other words, it would be
the length of the segment
joining the point 'P' to
the point 'Q' here.
What I claim is that if I
instead tried to find the
length of 'PR', the change in
'y' not along the curve but
along the line tangent to the
curve at the point 4.64, this
is what I can find
fairly rapidly.
In other words, what I am going
to do is to work this
same idea here with
a special case.
You see, I'm going to take 'x1'
to equal 4 and 'delta x'
to be 0.01.
Now you see the curve is
'y' equals 'x cubed'.
From this I can compute 'dy
dx' rather quickly.
Now, I don't want 'dy dx' at
any old point, I want to
compute it when 'x' is
4 so I can find the
slope of the line 'L'.
And when 'x' is 4 this, of
course, simply is what?
4 squared is 16,
times 3 is 48.
So what do I have?
I have that the slope is 48.
I also have that 'delta
x' is 0.01.
So according to my recipe,
'delta y-tan' is what?
It's 'dy dx' evaluated at 'x'
equals 4, which is 48, times
'delta x', which is 0.01.
And that's 0.48.
See again, let's just
juxtaposition these two.
All I have done now is computed
this recipe in the
particular example of trying
to find the cube of 4.01.
And you see, now notice that
this point 0.48 is exactly the
length of the accented
line here.
It's the length of 'PR'.
And what we do know is that the
height from the x-axis to
'R' is now exactly what?
Well, it's the 64
plus the 0.48.
This then is our
approximation.
And notice that this
compares with what?
The precise answer, which
is 64.481201.
In other words, notice what a
small error we happen to have
in this particular case.
And this is the way the subject
is usually brought up.
It is not a very important thing
from my point of view.
In other words, I think it's
rather easy to see that, first
of all, this approximation is
rather nebulous in the sense
that it requires a knowledge of
how fast the tangent line
is separating from the curve.
And this is a rather difficult
topic in its own right.
And secondly, this was a
rather simple example.
And we had the luxury here, you
see, of being able to find
the exact answer so we could
compare our approximation with
the exact answer.
In many cases it is difficult
or impossible to find the
exact answer.
To emphasize this more
abstractly and more generally,
let's consider the following.
Instead of trying to find
the cube of 4.01, the
generalization here is what?
That we could take the curve
'y' equals 'x cubed'.
The derivative of 'y' with
respect to 'x' would then be
'3 x squared'.
Evaluated at an arbitrary point
'x' equals 'x1', we
would get '3 x sub 1 squared'.
In which case 'delta y-tan'
would be '3 x1 squared'
times 'delta x'.
Could we have computed
the exact value of
'delta y' had we wished?
And the answer, of
course, is yes.
Namely, what is the exact
value of 'delta y'?
Well, we want to compute
this between 'x' equals
'x1' plus 'delta x'.
Well, what is the value of 'y'
when 'x' is 'x1 plus delta x'?
It's ''x1 plus delta
x' cubed'.
Then we subtract
off 'x1 cubed'.
And if we expand this,
watch what happens.
By the binomial theorem we get
an 'x1 cubed' term here, which
cancels with the 'x1 cubed'
term over here.
Then we get what?
A '3 x1 squared delta
x', so using the
binomial theorem here.
And then what else do we get?
We get plus '3x1 delta x
squared' plus 'delta x cubed'.
And you see, what I'd like to
have us view over here is if
we look at just this much of the
answer, this part here is
precisely what we sought to
be 'delta y-tan' before.
See, this is 'delta y-tan'.
And what's left over is the
difference, of course, between
'delta y-tan' and delta y.
After all, delta y is just
'delta y-tan' plus this
portion here.
And and now if you look at this
particular portion over
here, observe that, as we
expected, what the size of
this thing is depends both on
where we're measuring 'x1',
and also on how big the size
of the interval is,
namely 'delta x'.
And notice something
that we're going to
come back to here.
Notice that the 'delta x' factor
here appears at least
to the second power.
In other words, notice over
here that as 'delta x' get
small, both of these terms
get small very rapidly.
Because, you see, when 'delta x'
is close to 0 the square of
a number close to 0 is
even closer to 0.
But you see the important thing
for now is to notice
that this is the error in
approximating 'delta y' by
'delta y-tan'.
And that this error depends both
on 'xy' and 'delta x'.
And the question is, can we
state that in a little bit
more of a mathematical
language?
The answer, of course,
is that we can.
In particular, what we're
saying is let's take the
difference between 'dy dx' at
'x' equals 'x1', namely the
slope of the tangent line, and
what the average change of 'y'
with respect to 'x' is
along the curve.
Now, this is very typical
in mathematics.
And it's a very nice trick
to learn, and a very
quick trick to learn.
We know that these two things
are not equal and so all we do
is tack on a correction
factor.
We tack on 'k'.
What is 'k'?
'k' is the difference between
these two expressions.
In other words, by definition
I add on the difference of
these two numbers and that
makes this an equality.
Notice, by the way, that
'k' is a variable.
It depends on how big
'delta x' is.
You see, notice that once
'x1' is chosen--
and this is an important
observation.
As messy as this thing looks,
it's a fixed number for a
particular value of 'x1'.
Namely, we compute the
derivative and evaluate it
when 'x' equals 'x1'.
This is a number.
This, of course, clearly
depends on the
size of 'delta x'.
'Delta y' depends
on 'delta x'.
At any rate, here's
what we do.
We recognize that 'dy dx' is
the limit of 'delta y' over
'delta x' as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
So with this as a hint, we take
the limit of both sides
here as 'delta x'
approaches 0.
Notice the structure again.
In our last series
of lectures we
talked about limit theorems.
We talked about the limit of
a sum being the sum of the
limits, and things
of this type.
And now, you see, we're going
to use these results.
What we do is we take the limit
of both sides here as
'delta x' approaches 0.
The point being what?
That the limit of a sum is
the sum of the limits.
So when I take the limit of this
entire side I can express
that as the sum of the limits.
It is the limit of this term as
'delta x' approaches 0 plus
the limit of this term as
'delta x' approaches 0.
Now let's stop to think what
these things mean.
The limit of 'delta x'
approaching 0 of 'delta y'
divided by 'delta x' is
precisely the definition of
derivative.
In other words, this term here
is just the 'dy dx'.
And keep in mind we've
evaluated this
at 'x' equals 'x1'.
That's the point at which
we're starting.
Now the fact that this is a
constant, and we've already
learned that the limit of
a constant as 'delta x'
approaches 0 is that constant,
this term here is also 'dy dx'
evaluated at 'x' equals 'x1'.
And of course this term here
is just the limit of 'k' as
'delta x' approaches 0.
And now you see if we look at
this, since all we have to do
is observe that this term
appears on both sides of the
equation, canceling, or
subtracting equals from
equals, we wind up with the
result that the limit of 'k'
as 'delta x' approaches
0 is 0.
And we're going to talk more
about that pictorially and
analytically in a
little while.
But from this result, all I'm
going to do now is go back to
our first statement here.
Remembering that 'delta x' is
a nonzero number, I will
simply multiply both sides of
this equation by 'delta x'.
And if I do that, what
do I wind up with?
I wind up with that 'delta y'
is 'dy dx' evaluated at 'x'
equals 'x1' times 'delta
x' plus 'k delta x'.
Now, if I keep in mind here that
if I take the slope at a
particular point and multiply
that by the change in 'x',
that that's precisely what we
define to be 'delta y-tan'.
If I put this all together
I get what?
That 'delta y' is equal to
''delta y-tan' plus 'k delta
x'', where the limit of 'k' as
'delta x' approaches 0 is 0.
Now you see, when we started
this program and started to
talk at the beginning of our
lecture about approximations,
we did something that
was quite crude.
The crude part was
simply this.
What we had said was, why don't
we compute 'delta y' by
computing 'delta
y-tan' instead.
In other words, this is a very
easy thing to compute.
It's just a derivative
multiplied by a change in 'x'.
This is a very simple
thing to compute.
And we'll use that as an
approximation for the thing
that we really want,
which is 'delta y'.
The question that we
deliberately overlooked at
this point was how big was the
error when you do this?
And what we discovered was
something very interesting
and, by the way, may be
something which teaches us why
the analysis is better than the
picture even though the
picture is easier
to visualize.
You see, we knew intuitively
that as you picked a smaller
neighborhood at the
point of tangency.
the tangent line became
a better and better
approximation to the
curve itself.
This boxed-in result tells
us much more than that.
What this tells us is, look, if
this term by itself became
small as 'delta x' approached
0, this would still say the
same thing.
This says much more than that.
You see, what this says is--
and watch, this is very,
very profound--
as 'delta x' approaches 0, 'k'
is also approaching 0.
In other words, the term 'k'
times 'delta x' seems to be
approaching 0 much more rapidly
than 'delta x' itself.
That, by the way, in as simple
a way as I know how, defines
what an infinitesimal is.
See, 'k' times 'delta x' is
called an infinitesimal
because it goes to 0 faster
than 'delta x' itself.
In other words, anything that
approaches 0 faster than
'delta x' itself approaches 0
is called an infinitesimal
with respect to 'delta x'.
Now I'm not going to go into a
long philosophical discussion
about that.
Rather, I'm going to let the
actions speak louder than the
words, and try to show why this
is such a crucial idea.
In other words, again let
me emphasize that.
What's crucial here is not so
much that the error goes to 0,
it's that the error goes
to 0 much faster than
'delta x' goes to 0.
See, what is the error?
The error is 'k' times
'delta x'.
That's the difference between
these two things.
Again, if you want to see what
this thing means pictorially,
and I wish I knew a better way
of doing this but I don't,
notice that 'k' times 'delta
x' was defined to be the
difference between 'delta
y' and 'delta y-tan'.
In other words, since this
length here is 'delta y-tan',
and since this entire length
would be called 'delta y',
again the accented line, this
length here, is 'k'
times 'delta x'.
And what does it mean to say
that 'k' approaches 0 as
'delta x' approaches 0?
What it means is this.
It means that not only does this
vertical difference get
small as 'delta x' goes to 0,
but more importantly, it means
that this vertical distance
gets small very rapidly
compared to how 'delta
x' get small.
Now how can I prove that?
Well I'm not even going
to try to prove that.
What I'm going to just try to do
is to have you see from the
picture what's happening here.
See, here is a fairly
large 'delta x'.
And the difference between
'delta y' and 'delta y-tan'
for that large 'x' is this
length over here.
Now suppose we take a
smaller 'delta x'.
In other words, let's
take 'delta x' to be
this length over here.
Notice that the length of 'delta
x' here is still quite
significant.
I think if you look at this
you can see it's a fairly
significant length.
On the other hand, notice what
the difference between 'delta
y' and 'delta y-tan' is now.
It's just this little tiny
thing over here.
In other words, notice that
as 'delta x' gets small,
ratio-wise as 'delta x' get
small, the vertical difference
between the tangent line and the
curve is getting small at
a much faster rate.
Now of course the question is
why is that so important?
And the answer will always
come back to our
old friend of 0/0.
In general, if you tell a person
that the numerator of a
fraction is small, he jumps to
the conclusion that the size
of the fraction must be small.
But you see, the trouble is when
the denominator is also
small then we cannot
conclude that the
fraction itself is small.
And therefore in trying to
cancel out a term as being
insignificant, when we're
dealing with something like
this, it is no longer enough
to say but the numerator is
going to 0.
Let me jump ahead to the topic
that will be covered in our
next lecture just to use this
as an insight as to what we
have to see and what's
going on over here.
Let me just show you what
I mean by this.
let's go back to our recipe,
which says 'delta y' is this
thing over here where what?
This is important to put in
here, the limit of 'k' as
'delta x' approaches 0 is 0.
Now all I'm going to do
something like this.
Let's suppose we're dealing in
a situation where 'y' and 'x'
happen to be functions, say of,
't' as well, some third
variable 't'.
And what we really want
to find is 'dy dt'.
You see, what we'd be tempted
to do is simply say what?
Let's divide through
by 'delta t'.
We do this, we divide through
Then we take the limit of
this thing as 'delta
t' approaches 0.
Now what happens?
As 'delta t' approaches
0, this is a sum.
The limit of a sum is the
sum of the limits.
Each of the terms in the
sum is a product.
And the limit of a product is
the product of the limits.
So working out the regular limit
theorems, this is what?
The limit, 'delta t' approaches
0, 'dy dx'
evaluated at 'x' equals 'x1',
times the limit of 'delta x'
divided by 'delta t' as 'delta
t' approaches 0, plus the
limit of 'k' as 'delta t'
approaches 0, times the limit
of 'delta x' divided by 'delta
t' as 'delta t' approaches 0.
Now, if we remember what this
thing here means, this is just
by definition 'dy dt'.
For the sake of brevity I will
leave out subscripts now, but
we'll just talk about this.
This is a constant, and the
limit of constant as 'delta t'
approaches 0 is just that
constant, which
I'll call 'dy dx'.
It's understood this is
evaluated at 'x' equals 'x1'.
By definition the limit of
'delta x' divided by 'delta t'
as 'delta t' approaches 0,
that's called 'dx dt'.
Now we come to this
term over here.
And here's the key point.
Many people say, well, as
'delta t' goes to 0
so does 'delta x'.
That makes the numerator here
0 and that makes the whole
fraction 0.
But the point is that's
not true.
What is true here is that both
the numerator and denominator
are going to 0.
This does not make this 0, but
rather it makes it what?
'dx dt'.
That's the definition
of 'dx dt'.
The important point is what?
That as 'delta t' approaches
0 so does 'delta x'.
And what property
does 'k' have?
'k' has the property that the
limit of 'k' as 'delta x'
approaches 0 is 0 itself.
In other words, the topics that
we'll be talking about in
our next lecture concerns
this recipe.
And in the development of this
recipe, the reason that the
error term drops out is not
because the numerator of this
term was small, it was because
the number multiplying limit
happened to be 0.
Now, we will talk about that
in more detail next time.
But the message I want you to
see for right now is how we
get hung up on this 0/0 bit,
and why we must always be
careful in how we handle
something like this.
Now, by the way, there is
something rather interesting
that does happen over here.
If you look at this thing, you
get the feeling that it's
almost as if you could cancel a
common factor from both the
numerator and the denominator.
We have to be very,
very careful.
And I would like to introduce
the language which you will be
reading in the text in this
assignment, called
'Differentials Now'.
And what that means
is simply this.
Notice that 'dy dx' is one
symbol it is not 'dy' divided
by 'dx' because these things
have not been defined
separately.
In other words, you can't just
operate with symbols the way
you might like to.
Here's an interesting little
aside that you may find
entertaining if it has no other
value at all: the idea
of being told that you can
cancel common factors from
both numerator and
denominator.
The uninitiated may say,
you know, here's a 6
and here's a 6.
I'll cancel them out.
Now this is not what
cancellation really meant,
even though you had the same
number both upstairs and
downstairs.
This is not what we meant
by cancellation.
Yet, notice that you happen to,
by accident, get the right
answer in this particular
case.
You see, if you do cancel
this, this does
happen to be 1/4.
This lecture has been going on
in kind of a dull way for you.
Just in case you'd like some
comic relief, there are a few
other examples that
work the same way.
And you can amaze your friends
at the next party with them.
I mean 19/95 happens
to be 1/5.
26/65 happens to be 2/5.
And I think there's one more.
49/98 happens to be 4/8.
But these, I believe, are
the only four fractions
that this works for.
In other words, the mere fact
that it looks like something
is going to work is no guarantee
that you can do
these things without running
into trouble.
On the other hand, it's fair
to assume that the men who
invented differential calculus
must've been clever enough not
to have invented a symbolism
that would have
gotten us into trouble.
That, by the way, is a big
assumption to make, that they
must have been clever enough.
We will find, in places during
our course, that this was not
always the case.
The point is this though.
That when you write 'dy dx' in
this way, if it were not going
to be somehow identifiable with
a quotient such as 'dy'
divided by 'dx', the chances
are we would never have
invented this notation
in the first place.
And so what I'd like
to just point out
briefly now is the following.
Can we, in fact we should,
how shall we--
let's put it this way--
how shall we define separate
symbols dy and dx so that when
we write down 'dy dx' it will
make no difference whether you
think of this as being the
derivative or whether you
think of it as being the
quotient of two numbers?
And by the way, you see the
answer to this question will
not be that difficult if we
stop to think for just a
moment over here.
We've already answered this
question except that we
haven't concentrated
on the fact that
we solved the problem.
See, let's go back to
this line 'L' again.
What is the slope
of the line 'L'?
On the one hand we've looked
at slope as the
derivative 'dy dx'.
On the other hand, just by
looking at this little
accentuated triangle here, the
slope of the line 'L' is also
given by 'delta y-tan'
divided by 'delta x'.
And now one of the best ways
to define 'dy' and 'dx'
separately, it would seem
to me, is what?
Notice that this number divided
by this number yields
the symbol 'dy dx'.
Therefore why not define this
number to be 'dy' and define
this number to be 'dx'?
In other words the symbol 'dx'
will just be a fancy
name for 'delta x'.
On the other hand, the symbol
'dy' will not be a fancy name
for 'delta y'.
In fact, let's emphasize that.
It's not equal to 'delta y', it
is equal to 'delta y-tan'.
In other words, if I allow
'dy' to stand for 'delta
y-tan' and 'dx' to stand for
'delta x', I can now treat 'dy
dx' as if it were what?
'dy' divided by 'dx'.
Well, that's easy to show in
terms of an example just
mechanically.
Remember, given 'y' equals
'x cubed' we've
already found what?
That 'dy dx' is '3 x squared'.
This thing practically begs to
be treated like a fraction.
We would like to be able to say,
hey, if this divided by
this is this, why isn't this
equal to this times this?
In other words, why isn't 'dy'
equal to '3 x squared' dx'?
And the answer is that since
we've identified or defined
'dy' to be 'delta y-tan', and
since we've defined 'dx' to be
'delta x', and since we already
know that this recipe
is correct, it means, in
particular, that we can now
write things like this without
having to worry about whether
it's proper or not.
Now in later lectures this
is going to play a
very important role.
This is what is known as the
language of differentials.
And differentials are the
backbone off both differential
and integral calculus.
But the thing that I want you
to really get into our minds
today is the basic
overall recipe.
And I've taken the liberty of
boxing this off over here.
I want you to practice
with approximations.
I want you to think carefully
about how you can get quick
approximations.
I don't want you to come away
with the feeling that the
approximation is what
was important.
What was important was what?
That the change in 'y', the true
'delta y', is ''dy dx'
times 'delta x'' plus 'k delta
x', where the limit of 'k' as
'delta x' approaches 0 is 0.
And by the way, again, most
books write it this way.
I prefer that we emphasize
that the derivative is
evaluated or taken at a
particular value of 'x'.
And finally what I'd like to
point out is that again, and
we've done this many, many
times, whereas the language
we're used to in terms of
intuition is geometry, that
these results make perfectly
good sense without reference
to any diagram at all.
In other words, then, the same
result stated in analytic
language simply says this: if
'f' is a function of 'x' and
is differentiable when 'x'
equals 'x1', then 'f of 'x1
plus delta x'' minus
'f of x1'--
you see that's geometrically
what corresponds
to your 'delta y'.
That's ''f prime of x1' times
'delta x'' plus 'k delta x'
where the limit of 'k' as 'delta
x' approaches 0 is 0.
Now these two recipes summarize
precisely what it is
that we are interested in when
we deal with the subject
called infinitesimals.
As I said before, and I can't
emphasize this thing strongly
enough, when it comes time to
make approximations we will
find better ways of getting
approximations than by the
method known as differentials
and 'delta y-tan'.
What is crucial is that you
use the language of
approximations enough so as you
can see pictorially what's
going on and then cement down
the final recipe, which I've
boxed in here.
This will be the building block,
as we shall see you
next time, in the lecture which
develops the derivative
of composite functions.
But more about that next time.
And until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.